oh
je suis disposé à les lâcher
attendez je vais présenter ça va super
amiral je vous présente jamais de vous
le présenter
ça va mieux je connecte nouveaux
aéroports tous les reproches généticien
pages qui attend juste géante écoute moi
qu'est ce qu'il fait là
ouais comme je sais que tu as beaucoup
de boulot hein tu travaille comme un
forcené
j'ai préparé le but ce que j'ai lu très
long à lire prend son temps wipro de
surtemps évidemment c'est parce que
j'aurai comme j'ai pas le temps moi
c'est pour ça j'ai je laisse tirer lire
il me raconte arrière il regarde tout le
monde en parle pour savoir ce qu'elle
est les flics très bien organisée en
tout cas observés pour radio londres
j'ai quitté mon corps aussi je vous ai
déjà dit et l'appel du 18 juin comme je
suis né le 18 juin ça me fait kiffer
c'est parti personne alors j'étais en
train d'écrire et escompte mois moi je
décris les questions pour pas que perdre
ton temps tu m'as fait des questions en
tout cas ravi de me poser des questions
à la con du style tromper csu c'est la
corde pépère je me mélange fait comme si
j'étais pas au courant de questions mais
bon vous restait cinq minutes avec nous
je vous remercie japon djamel qu'est ce
que vous faites là n'entend jamais avant
chanel
bon j'en ai dit c'est bon tu respires
jamais benjamin a oui je crois que
c'était benja mail
mais sans tomber est sans tomber jeudi à
remettre dans l'ordre j'amène on y va
jamel bonsoir bonsoir thiery alors jamel
c'est vraiment un honneur un immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un des acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
ouais le panthéon c'est la fin mais on
lui
là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de choses
à faire l'achat n'a alors jamais c'est
vraiment un honneur et un immense
privilège d'avoir l'honneur de vous
avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
ouais je sais pas si risqué panthéon ou
arc de triomphe pour effet les gens rien
à [ __ ] c'est plus difficile c'est pas
moi c'est les jo c'est les autres qui
vont au moins une certaine envahie
extraordinaire moi je suivis plus tu
vois je suis pas trop grand je fais je
fais des choses naturellement pensé
c'est le style c'est le style c'est
clair pourtant djamel d'après le journal
de mickey vous êtes l'acteur préféré les
enfants je tiens à remercier les enfants
en particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai
et c'est s'est joué ça s'est joué à ça
un autre mois plus tôt et c'est vrai
qu'entre un chien débile il a rappelé
qu'à la classe et ont préféré le réseau
jamel jamel c'est quoi vos plus grandes
qualités à part bien sûr la bogossité la
générosité la même minute r ça et iris
est très difficile de parler de soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire là la modestie
oui oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si
ça s'est fait de gens modestes ou très
modestes syfy de vaud l'a alors c'est
qu'il vend des livres c'est incroyable
ils vont vingt mille livres par jour
j'avais une énorme le en vente 500
milles la rêverie c'est dans les
premières rampes - son effigie et
d'éviter comme des aéroports des deux
métros voici mois ci ses amis voilà
c'est ça que voir terme aussi un jour y
a égalé un record qui s'appelle le jamel
debbouzze comment je suivrai t'imagines
imagine tu imagines si philippe devaux
le premier du pognon sur charles de
gaulle roissy charles de gaulle étoile
station charles de gaulle il faut il
pour s acheter plein de cravate bordeaux
alors que jamais elle en 2002 d'après le
figaro vous êtes devenu l'acteur
français le mieux payé
oui mais d'ailleurs ça va causer pas mal
de temps je dois avouer
parce que maintenant j'ai j je vois
venir plein de nouveaux cousins qui sont
en galère d'oseille way qui débarque
comme ça il ya un accord il ya un mec
qui est venu me voir en disant je suis
le fils de ton père tu dis donc ça
voudrait dire qu'il serait mon frère
elle m'a dit ouais je suis ton frère je
t'aime mon fils veut rien dire du tout
passé à cause du figaro était en pleine
crise d'identité alors oui effectivement
il faut j'aimerais remercier le figaro
pour cet article de bâtards bons djamel
alors c'est votre grand retour sur scène
en décembre vous êtes venus ici pour en
parler merci pas du tout thierry je suis
venu en toute amitié
je suis pas venu faire de la promo bombe
c'est vrai que c'est mon grand retour
sur scène en même temps faut faire un
petit peu je joue au bataclan une charge
à partir du 23 décembre jusqu'au 11
janvier
c'est casino de paris 23 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier au casino de paris
après j'enchaîne avec le bataclan 10 13
au 18 janvier après c'est vrai que
l'olympia arrive le 20 janvier jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive
c'est pas plus pour en parler de la
question et si vous voulez louer les
placer à la fnac ou virgin
le nouveau spectacle de jamel c'est quoi
le spectacle ça va s'appeler djamel 100%
debbouze est pourquoi est-ce que je
n'appelle jamais le double c'est une
bonne sinon je rappelais différemment
jamais vous pouvez nous dire en deux
mots de quoi ça parle de moi à de vous
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle djamel
100% debbouze en fin de mois
si on m'avait dit vous pouvez me dire ça
en plusieurs mois j'aurais fait j'aurais
dit autre chose mais là maintenant pas
voilà enfin venir voir le spectacle pour
savoir ne placez pas ça parle uniquement
de moi quoi ça s'appelle l'église et de
causticité à son paroxysme de questions
stupides dans le temps c'est ce et ses
fonds propres dans mon premier spectacle
je racontais un petit peu j'étais très
surpris de faire ce métier avec tout ce
que ça implique et emmanuel de là que je
suis vraiment de bons c'est encore plus
étonnant c'est ce que je raconte ce que
je vais tâcher de raconter vous croyez
que ça va intéresser les gens parce que
tu crois pour décor de merde il
intéresse les gens
exactement pour faire pour venir te voir
avec l'émission team demande si ça va
intéresser les gens tu crois pas de
franchement sever et les pourris et ces
tags chez pas qui c'est ta grand-mère
kbc d'amesys et la musique et a sorti
son île et orties musique ont fait des
tags le fait qu'il devait être sous jb
c'est impossible je vais te montrer ce
que c'est dingue de tac est exactement
je vais faire venir des aguias mois on
compte montrer ce que c'est que d'être
un quand tu t'inquiètes pas encore
encore une question monsieur bouge
maintenant que vous avez un succès
énorme que vous croulez sous les
sollicitations
vous pouvez nous dire est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper tu vois qu'il veut pas
temps d'empêcher tu vois je te jure
qu'elle va profondément un syndic
tu dois tu dois être bon scolaire qui
doit être fait huit ans a dit cité c'est
pas possible tu es pas obligé de me
poser la question est ce que si c'est
trop toutes les stars je ne peux pas te
répondre à ces deux questions je préfère
me taire la mère regarde l'émission
avant pc ramadan et à jamel est ce que
tant qu'il est là c'est assez incroyable
de laval va revenir au mois de février
philippe de gaulle mais est ce que tu es
ce que tu as une question à lui poser
monsieur philippe de gaulle vous êtes
donc le fils forcément de charles est ce
que il aimer le rap est ce qu'ils
connaissaient tupac shakur biggie smalls
par exemple de son temps et il lui
arrivait de danse et de partir en vrille
ou par branches et non mais regardez les
gens danser mais jamais jamais voulait
prendre pris en flag dans votre salon en
train
jamais non jamais jamais il singe est
épuisé il était très strictes leurs
cartes postales non c'est pas ça mais
comme ce n'était pas dans son talent il
préférait regarder ceux dont le talent
mais parce qu'on voit les chefs d'état
en bas de mon point de vue en tout cas
je suis pas chef d'état de mon état je
me dis que y
ils sont toujours obligés tout le temps
toute leur vie d'être sérieux oui sans
vous sérieux mais ça les empêche pas de
s'amuser parfois mais c'est un jeu sans
rire à tous de nous quand même s'ils
sont pas un sourire et qu'on les voit
pas rire il ya des choses qui les amuse
il n'a jamais nouvelle touche de
résilience du frère de temps il et il
était plutôt gentil plus tôt et tout
sage plutôt chefs d'état les gentilles
et état ils avaient affaire avec
difficulté et forcément il n'y a pas que
ça ferme c'est réparé on l'avait fait
venir pour ça ouais non ça c'était un
peu aller le chercher
si c'est allé le chercher dans tout ça a
fait comme on dit chez moi
merci beaucoup merci vie des deux bords
le bol mon père
entretien avec michel tauriac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu